monsieur revécu au bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
la fermeture des restaurants et cafés
est repoussée à demain soir on imagine
que c'est toujours l'incompréhension et
la colère qui prédomine à marseille
êtes-vous vous-même concernés par cette
restriction cette fermeture de
l'établissement à salon de provence
alors en fait depuis hier soir l art
était tombé hier soir tard on est sur sa
lancée au plus concernés en fait à part
ces mesures là on sera on a la chance de
pouvoir continuer à travailler par
contre bien évidemment on reste
solidaires de nos collègues en fait de
marseille et de et d'aix est ce que vous
comprenez cette mesure qui a essayé de
défendre
hier justement olivier vers en
déplacement à marseille
alors moi je reste en fait je vais vous
dire je l'assuré sur les positions de
disant qu' il n'y a pas plus de chance
de contracter le coup vide au sein d'un
restaurant d'un bar
pour moi la chance de de contracter le
virus en fait elle est partout là où il
ya du monde
elle est dans tous les lieux publics
dans tous les lieux d'accueil sur ce
point tous les lieux qui reçoivent du
public en fait tout simplement
y a pas plus de chance d'être dans un
bar et dans l'est dans un resto je pense
entre autres aux transports en commun
je pense à plein de lieux comme cela en
fait quelle mesure vous même vous
appliquez justement dans votre
restaurant parce que on a pu observer
quand même un certain relâchement de la
part de certains restaurateurs ou les
tables étaient de plus en plus
rapprochées des gestes barrières à
observer tout à fait vrai c'est vite
lancé ce que je disais encore ce matin
on a la chance ou sur salon et le
périmètre autour de pouvoir continuer à
travailler mais il appartient à chacun
de rester vigilant on a mis en place à
la couverture le 2 juin
bien évidemment tous les gestes
barrières on a dû s'équiper avec une
bande ses muscles et de gérer pour les
clients on a une borne à l'entrée de
l'établissement sur la terrasse sur une
borne dès que vous entrez dans la salle
du bas on a une borne également
à l'entrée à la sortie des toilettes on
applique les gestes barrière nous
désinfectant les mains régulièrement
nettoyés nettoyant les poignées en
portant le masque bien évidemment l'âge
des paniers ou l'interview mais c'est la
responsabilité de chacun en fait c'est
ce que je disais en fait c'est le libre
arbitre de chacun
il faut qu'on ait le droit de continuer
à travailler il faut que nos clients
aient le droit et la liberté de venir le
voir en leur âme et conscience il faut
bien sûr je pense pour ça qu'on passe
peut-être une bague de contrôle pour
être sûr que tout le monde répond à ces
normes là et pour ceux qui
éventuellement n'y répondrai pas laisser
quelques jours voir se mettre aux normes
et éventuellement peut-être une amende
éventuellement après si délai est passé
fermer l'établissement les devants à la
maire de marseille a affirmé qu'elle
n'allait pas sanctionner les
établissements qui resteraient ouverts
malgré la mise en place de cette mesure
vous avez sûrement des confrères qui se
trouve justement dans la cité phocéenne
est ce qu'ils vont observer
voilà cette restriction ou laisser leur
établissement ouvert je pense que voilà
prêt il appartient comme je disais
qu'est quiz est parti à chacun de faire
ou pas moi j'avais pris la décision
avant que comme je le dis depuis tout à
l'heure pour avoir la chance de
continuer à travailler mais j'ai appelé
un de rester ouvert je pense vraiment
que si on oblige tous les établissements
à fermer
c'est bien évidemment un manque de
chiffres un manque de trésorerie et
certains peuvent se retrouver
j'ai envie de dire et tout fait je pense
aux personnes qui travaillent peut-être
tout seul dans ce cas là ce ces quinze
jours de recettes en moins ça peut être
fatal
c'est dans ce sens là en fait que que je
dis c'est que je mène ce combat entre
guillemets parce que pour certains ces
quinze jours de fermeture peuvent être
fatales tout simplement
après la première vague est le premier
confinement on sait que l'état a promis
des aides justement aux secteurs les
plus touchés on allait vous bénéficiez
vous même alors on a bénéficié comme
tout le monde pendant la période de
confinement des 1500 euros mensuels mais
après c'est déjà bien bien sûr mais
c'est pas suffisant pour faire face à
toutes les charges comme j'ai dix ans
que les charges ont été reportés pour ce
dernier trimestre
justement pendant ces derniers
trimestres on travaille le mieux mais le
plus aussi pour pouvoir s'acquitter de
charges
merci beaucoup en tout cas monsieur
henri baker d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
gérant du restaurant l'authentic à salon
de marseille à salon de provence ion
merci